the next category is achievements in
short subjects and two people to
represent them the very beautiful hope
line and the very talented young actor
who also writes the kisses for Dinah
Shore mr. Carl Reiner
there are two awards for short subjects
one for live-action and one for cartoons
first hope while it's obvious while miss
Langdon is here I'd like to explain my
association with this category you've
all seen those coming attractions that
se+ selected short subjects well before
I became an actor I was a courageous
young chap who selected them nobody
selected this joke selected by the
Academy members for this year's Oscars
the nominees for live-action short
subjects are between the tides ayan
Ferguson producer the golden fish
jacques-yves cousteau producer mysteries
of the deep Walt Disney producer the
running jumping and standing still film
Peter Sellers producer skyscraper
Shirley Clark Willard Van Dyke and
earthen Jacobi producers and the winner
is the goldfish jockey for stove
accepting the award for mr. Jacque
Cousteau is miss Jo Bora on behalf of
the director excuse me my first time on
behalf of the director ed monster song
administration for Americans and the
producer jacques-yves cousteau thank you
our two nominees are Mexicali schmoes
John W Burton producer moonbird John
Hubley producers Noah's Ark Walt Disney
producer the violinist Ernest Pinto
producer the winner is moonbird john
Hubley
I want to thank everyone Academy very
much and I must share this with five
people Bob cannon Edie Smith
babe Elliott and Mark II and Hampi thank
you